in another
vaccine-related
occurrence
you know it's
i don't even
it is a strange thing to me that there
are certain people who just love to be
owned
and and peter ducey the dingus over at
fox news who is now their white house
correspondent which used to be
a a lofty position something you would
strive for because it meant you were at
the top of your game instead nepotism
junior over there at fox news
he's the he's the correspondent well
yesterday at the briefing
it was uh sunday sunday sunday it's like
a monster truck rally with peter ducey
just getting smashed
by jhinsaki
this moment transpired and buckle up
because it is
president tries to reach unvaccinated
americans has there been any thought
given looking back
to the possibility that he may have
created
some vaccine hesitancy when last year
around this time the previous
administration
was rushing to get a vaccine authorized
and the now president said i trust
vaccines i trust scientists but i don't
trust donald trump at this moment the
american people can't either
well i think it's safe to say he still
doesn't trust donald trump so that
hasn't changed but he does trust
scientists he does trust data experts
and he does trust the people leading the
cdc the fda
which is the gold standard of approval
for vaccines i'd also note because this
question often comes up that the
president has repeatedly given credit to
uh scientists and experts from the prior
administration even as recently as just
a few weeks ago for their role in moving
the vaccine forward yes but at the time
when donald trump is out there saying
we're going to have a vaccine in the
next couple weeks next couple months
and joe biden is out on the campaign
trail saying don't trust donald trump
did that create any kind of vaccine
hesitancy
not that we've seen in the data i would
note that at the time just for context
the former president was also suggesting
people inject versions of poison into
their veins to cure covet so i think
that's a relevant point and joe biden
then vice president was saying we gotta
wait until something is fully authorized
and it's still not
well the fda works on the timeline and
of science at the same time we've also
seen tens of millions of people's lives
saved who have gotten the vaccine that
data is clear across the country go
ahead so peter ducey
is accusing joe biden
of creating vaccine hesitancy in the
united states
[Laughter]
oh
come on man
this is an unbelievable thing and by the
way a great off-the-cuff moment for
jinsaki to mention no no no no no you're
not going to do this your guy
your guy that you're fighting to defend
right now is the guy who remember and
i'm gonna play the clip because
it is one of those moments that we
should never forget it it's another one
of those moments that we should cherish
that we're not living in that era
anymore the era of donald trump when he
did absolutely unequivocally suggest
that people
that it could be
a workable solution to fight the virus
if we were to inject disinfectant into
our bodies supposing we hit the body
with a tremendous
whether it's ultraviolet or just very
powerful light
and i think you said that hasn't been
checked but you're going to test it
and then i said supposing you brought
the light inside the body you can which
you can do either through the skin or
uh in some other way
and i think you said you're going to
test that too sounds interesting
right and then i see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out
in a minute
one minute and is there a way we can do
something like that
by
injection inside or
or
almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number so it'd be interesting
to check that so that you're gonna have
to use
medical doctors with but it sounds it
sounds interesting to me so just
remember that
don't let
sidetracking questions from idiots like
peter ducey distract you
from the fact that one we have a
competent
empathetic
decent man as president of the united
states not now
not
not a dingus who who
dangerously suggests that disinfectant
could cure the virus inside the body
i mean there is something to rejoice
about is there not
one of our sponsors is geology the place
to go for men's skin care geology helps
men find a simple skincare routine that
works it's personalized for you by a
dermatologist and geology can help with
dark puffy eyes acne oily skin
protecting your skin against damage you
answer a few questions about your skin a
dermatologist will design a personalized
skin regimen for your needs you'll get a
30-day trial with the products they
recommend to try them out if you like
how it goes they'll keep sending it to
you these aren't bogus miracle creams
these are just the clinical
evidence-based products that
dermatologists have at their disposal
but they're tailored personally to you
based on the products you really need i
took the quiz a couple of months ago
their dermatologist matched me with a
regimen that's just great for me i've
been happy with the results my skin's
looking great i can actually see a
difference go and take geology's free
quiz and when you use my link right
underneath this video
you will save up to 40 percent off your
first paid month